what do you think about the joe rogan
deal there i am right there in that
garage and rocita man i rolled in
her and her husband do it that's so
goddamn funny
it was pretty good over there i gave her
a nice tip i felt like and
they were her husband has two kids that
he's divorced but he has two kids that
move to the town i'm from actually in
louisiana
and they're living over there how old
are they uh
they're not of age i mean the daughter
sounded hot but she's young
you know but that's what the lady said i
didn't say that i didn't ask
uh but uh rogan i think it's [ __ ]
awesome
i think it's what do you think it's
gonna do what do you think it's gonna do
well we talked about this on the phone i
don't think it's gonna do much
me i think it's good i think it's
unequivocally good
um because the like when howard stern
went from radio
to satellite it was almost like he left
popular culture whereas joe
podcast is already not it's already like
off the beaten path
so i think he's not gonna be reduced
culturally at all right like there's not
he's not gonna miss i don't i don't know
how much that means to him anyway but i
don't
he's not gonna be any less relevant
culturally
and uh it sounds like a lot of money
and with very little
downside it's like his listeners have to
listen to ads
i think this is there'll be a
subscription if you don't want to listen
to ads yeah same as youtube right
yeah yeah kind of it seems like he i
mean he's like the guy to do it because
he got like you said he got everything
he wanted he's licensed it so he's not
giving up ip
uh he can still put out youtube clips
which is like
his biggest growth more people watch his
clips than his full episodes on youtube
anyways
um yeah i don't see i don't see the
downside people are like oh spotify
might be able to control them a i think
that's why they don't want to control
him
i mean he's the reason he's popular is
because he talks about
ten things like you know what i mean i
don't think they're gonna be like could
you just focus on ufos
yeah like i it's just they're not gonna
and also
once if he feels like if he even sniffs
like they're trying to control him he'll
just go
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this i think that's why
he said [ __ ] this to youtube because
they are
doing some of that slightly censorship
thing i don't know are they really
yeah i mean just like if you talk about
corona
uh they'll demonetize you uh yeah and i
think that kind of stuff could just be
getting stronger you know as we go along
it definitely seems like on twitter it's
like extremely
it's a very liberal app it seems like
you know like um
so i think that and you know i think
that i could see some of the other
you know the giants some of the other
social media giants
and youtube's almost it's really kind of
like social media in a way
i mean it's but i'm curious to see what
spotify's new
interface is going to look like because
if they're going to start video
and they're going to have his full
episodes and then are they going to buy
other stuff to supplement it because
you can't just go there i promise you
they're gonna ask you schultz
uh santino i'm sure they've already
asked burr
obama does obama have a deal at spotify
that's a rumor that i heard
yeah honestly yeah that was back in june
already yeah
um so yeah like i'm sure they've already
asked burr i'm sure they've already
asked like the no
i mean they bill simmons they gave him a
hundred million like they gave him a
hundred million i think it was a hundred
yeah yeah i think 150 but the difference
there they bought the ringer actually
right joe rogan just licensed it right
um but uh they also pay amy schumer
uh she has a jumper show joe budden
yeah yeah joe buddy so like they'll
they'll you know i think they'd rather
have more than less there's no downside
i mean i
but like a lot of my podcast just
streams on spotify like
i don't joe wouldn't give it to them i
think
right and yeah i don't think i mean and
they're going to license i guess at a
certain point he'll be able to get it
all back
yeah well they take everything he has on
youtube and put it on to spotify the
full episode
yes and it's going to be like a slow
transition okay so it's been yeah
so he's got a huge library he's got
6 000 hours i would guess wow he's done
maybe not six thousand but definitely
three thousand yeah so i don't i think
it's good for both of them honestly
their stock went up ten percent yeah
like the on the announcement like
they're it's good that's all they wanted
um i wonder what their platform's gonna
be like or people i mean it is time for
youtube to have a competitor for sure
yeah and i don't know if that's the
that's
youtube's gonna be hard to compete with
because they have a 15-year lead and
yeah and they're owned by google and
like they just have a lot of [ __ ] going
for them
yeah um but yeah
that's the that's the i'm i'm happy for
joe and
it seems like there's no downside uh
i'm and i that if that's a smart
investment on their part i said
i think i said to you on the phone the
fact that comedy central
or a network never
got a bunch of podcasts
video podcasts and just put them on
comedy central yeah
at 10 30. the way he used to put
howard stern on is back it's still
baffling to me
it's still because you look at the
amount of hits that we get you'd be like
those better numbers than comedy central
numbers yeah
so why would you guys and i think it's
because they didn't feel like
they did it yeah like love line at night
remember even having a love line on that
was like having a podcast
basically just sitting there and that
was that was kind of a pop that was a
popular show
yes but loveline was the
like a produced version of the radio
show i don't even think they needed to
do all that
yeah they could have what people didn't
realize is this
is enough yeah this is enough they used
to i mean
howard stern used to show it and then
they acted like well that didn't happen
and then i guess imus did it on he used
to be on msnbc
uh it's gonna be i mean it's definitely
it's definitely gonna be interesting
yeah i think for
for joe it's really a no-lose he just
licenses
you know you know he can have it back
i'm guessing whenever he leaves
um the thing about joe is he doesn't
seem rich
right even though he's he's been rich
and now
he's ex now he's like getting to like
wealthy
yeah uh he doesn't see he just doesn't
hasn't really changed he hasn't he looks
he looks like he'd look if he worked
construction
yeah almost to the outfit yeah yeah yeah
like i saw nothing's different which is
part of his appeal he just doesn't
that's his sensibilities like t-shirts
and jeans and
yeah in a pocket full of fresh hulk meat
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one